يمكن أن تساعد حبوب منع الحمل التجريبية الأشخاص على
إنقاص الوزن بنفس فعالية
اللقطات الشائعة مثل Will Gobi و Ozempic ،
وجدت دراسة جديدة أن هذه الحبة من
شركة تصنيع الأدوية Eli Lilly ساعدت المستخدمين على
فقدان ما معدله 15 في المائة من
وزن أجسامهم في ثلاثة أشهر فقط CNN
دورة طبية على ميج تريل هنا
أنت تعلم أنني أشعر بالقلق بالطبع عندما أسمع
إصلاحًا سريعًا ،
لذا فهذه آثار جانبية جيدة مثل
اللقطة ، ما نعرفه ، حسنًا ، الآن
جميع الأدوية المتاحة يتم
حقنها ذاتيًا مرة واحدة في الأسبوع  لذا فإن
agovi هو الوحيد الذي تمت الموافقة عليه فعليًا
لفقدان الوزن ، حيث أن اختيار الأوزون هو نفس
الدواء ولكنه دليل على مرض السكري من النوع 2 ، ويجب
عليك إعطاؤهم كجرعات ،
وبالتالي هناك فئة جديدة من الأدوية التي
يتم تطويرها حيث
تأخذ  حبوب منع الحمل يوميًا وهي
تؤدي نفس الشيء بشكل أساسي وفي هذه البيانات الجديدة
التي نراها من
مؤتمر السكري خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، فإنها
تحقق في الواقع نفس القدر من
فقدان الوزن كما هو الحال مع Gobi حوالي 15
بالمائة وكانت هذه دراسة أكثر من 36
أسبوعًا وبدأ الأشخاص في
الدراسة بمتوسط ​​240 رطلاً في الدراسة ، وهكذا فإن
أعلى جرعة لم يتم فيها فقدان الوزن مطلقًا بمقدار
36 رطلاً على مدار 36 أسبوعًا ، ولكن كما
ذكرت الآثار الجانبية ،
فنحن نعلم أن الآثار الجانبية
للأوزمبياد والواغوفي  يمكن أن يكون غثيانًا سيئًا للغاية ، والإمساك ، يتقيأ
أشياء من هذا القبيل ،
وهذه الحبوب متشابهة مع ما
وجدوه هو أنه عندما تبدأ في تناول
الدواء ، فإنك تبدأ
بجرعة منخفضة ، وتنتقل إلى جرعة أعلى عندما
تشعر حقًا بالآثار الجانبية
ولذا فإن الأمل هو أنه يمكنك نوعًا ما
اكتشاف طريقة للقيام بذلك حيث
لا تشعر بالسوء تمامًا عندما تأخذهم معك ،
هل يمكنني أن أطرح السؤال الذي كان لدي
دائمًا وهو أنني أشعر مثل هؤلاء
تم إنشاء العقاقير للأشخاص الذين يعانون من
مخاطر صحية للأشخاص المصابين بمرض السكري ، وقد
أصبح هذا نوعًا شائعًا جدًا
من أنواع الصفقات في برنامجك التلفزيوني أو
برنامج الواقع ويبدو أن الجميع صريحون ،
هل هذا التحرك نحو ذلك هو
نوع من  هدف اللعبة هنا من
منظور السوق أم أنه لا يزال من
المفترض أن يركز على أولئك الذين يعانون من
مشاكل صحية ويحتاجون إليها جيدًا ، فإن
الشركات محددة جدًا بحيث لا
تستهدف سوى الدواء تجاه
المؤشرات المعتمدة من إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية (FDA) أو إذا كان للأشخاص الذين يعانون من مرض السكري من النوع 2
السمنة
وهناك بالفعل تجربة من المتوقع أن
تسفر عن نتائج هذا الصيف تُظهر أن
الأمل هو أن هذا يمكن أن
يقلل بالفعل من النوبات القلبية والسكتات الدماغية لدى
الأشخاص الذين لا يعانون من مرض السكري أيضًا
ولكن هناك مخاوف من أن يبدأ
استخدام هذا بشكل خاص.  في شكل حبوب للأشخاص
الذين قد لا يعرفون
خوف الشركة من ذلك ، فلا داعي للخوف ، هناك
سؤال واحد تعرف أنه من المحتمل أن يكون مثاليًا
ولكن أيضًا بعض
الآثار الجانبية الجيدة المحتملة مثل مساعدة الأشخاص على التوقف عن
شرب الأشياء التي كنا نتحدث
عنها معك قبل بضعة أسابيع توقف
السلوكيات التي تسبب الإدمان ، لذلك ربما يكون هناك تغيير كبير في قواعد اللعبة
على العديد من الجبهات. مايك
شكرًا جزيلاً لك